[Music]
thank you joining me now with more
reaction Jihad watch director Robert
Spencer the national spokesman for the
ahmadiya Muslim Community uh Kasam
Rashid is with us guys good to see you
uh Robert Spencer let me begin with you
you heard John Kerry you see the
president has dug his heels in and he's
insisting that America take in refugees
even though we're being warned by our
intelligence officials what is your
reaction to this and what does the
president what is John Kerry not getting
well it's insane to the point of
suicidal just today the Turks arrested
eight Islamic State operatives who were
posing as refugees on their way to get
into Europe and so what the president
and John Kerry are not getting what
they've never addressed is the
possibility of jihadis among the
refugees and yet that's the whole big
elephant in the room that has everybody
concerned about the refugee problem he
tried to make it into a religious effect
a problem of religious bigotry saying
some people want to only take in the
Christians and not the Muslims well the
reason for that is that Muslims might
blow us up and the Christians are not
going to Mr Rasheed is there a clash of
cultures if somebody comes from an area
of the world where they're taught that
women must stress a certain way that
women need four male eyewitnesses for
rape that women can't drive that women
can be seen in public without male
relatives is there a culture Clash
because that seems to be the direct
opposite of what we have here in America
and how do we ascertain if somebody
really wants to assimilate and have a
better life or whether or not somebody
secretly wants to engage in a caliphate
well Sean thanks for having me on today
uh as you know the Amity Muslim
Community as Muslims who believe in the
Messiah
have advocated for Universal human
rights since day one and the concerns
being brought up regarding the refugees
his Holiness the Khalifa of Islam the
true Khalifa Mirza Ahmed brought up
years ago that humanitarian values come
first we recognize the rights of all
human beings we should help refugees
without a doubt and there must be a
comprehensive
is America risking that Isis and Isis
related terrorists will infiltrate the
refugee Community as our intelligence
officials are suggesting they may very
well or we make I think risking American
lives by doing that sir
I think we're risking American dignity
if we don't help our refugees
that question I asked you is it likely
that Isis will infiltrate the refugee
population to get at America is that
likely
that that's what Isis has stated and if
we study history
Jewish refugees and we sent those Jewish
refugees back wait a minute very
tragically half of them died in the
Holocaust where you can't repeat the
mistakes of History out of fear okay but
maybe there's another way to help them
like for example a no-fly zone and and
Security in a certain area of Syria
where they can have Refuge humanitarian
assistance you know if this is what
they're saying Robert Spencer then
you're right this is suicidal this
President the only problem is
President's gambling with American lives
there'll be blood on his hands if people
in fact infiltrate and kill Americans
like they did in Paris
no doubt about it Sean look the Islamic
State told us this was coming they
threatened in February that they were
going to flood Europe with 500 000
refugees they weren't just trying to
trigger a social crisis they were going
to plant jihadis among the refugees
they've already boasted that they've
sent 4 000 into Europe more are coming
now Barack Obama without ever addressing
that is going to bring this population
over to the United States people are
going to die as a result of this
disastrous policy this is unbelievable
all right we have plenty more coming up
next here on Hannity